so with regards to a/b testing I know
that startups and websites will often do
this how do you know when to a/b test
and when not to good question I don't
have a baseline number for you in terms
of traffic for your app or your website
but my advice to new founders is always
when you're just getting started don't
don't waste your time I think a/b
testing is extremely powerful it's a
great way to look at large groups of
customers or visitors at once it's
awesome but when you're just getting
started you don't have large groups of
customers you've got a trickle at best
and your job at that point as a founder
is to understand those customers the
best you possibly can and there's no
substitute in that situation for sitting
down in front of somebody and having a
conversation watching them use your
product understanding where you're
falling short and so I always advise
founders at that stage spend your time
you know picking up the phone rather
than setting up baby testing wait for a
be testing when you've got a bit of
traction and you want to start making
data-driven decisions that way so really
essentially it's important to be close
to your user at all times I couldn't say
that enough as a founder yeah and tell
me a little bit more about how you go
about a/b testing and sort of you know
what's your decision behind running a/b
tests what do you what do you make sure
that you want to a beat s what should
you avoid a be testing so well first of
all the feet there are a set of features
which have contradictory kind of appeal
to the user base so for example a lot of
people on lock screen wouldn't want to
have the time and weather on the right
side but they want to have it on the
left side or they want to have a quick
access to the left and the unlock button
on the right so all these things have to
be a be tested we have to understand how
the user behaves and not just that for
example we wanted to disable this home
button and make sure that the lock
screen has a complete a pattern
protection law kind of thing but we did
not do it because in our a/b testing
results we found out that a lot of
people did not want the home button to
be disabled so had we disabled it
without knowing we would have spent a
lot of resource wasting building it
which not many people would appreciate
or use it well so that way we actually
go through all the day to be testing
okay so I mean that case it sounds like
you avoided going down a path that you
didn't didn't want to go yeah absolutely
great